foreign
let's roll out to Dave in Philadelphia
he was born and raised what's up Dave
what's up Dr John how are you I'm good
brother how are you
I'm good man I appreciate you uh you
taking the time
um so I wanted to reach out the the way
that I found you
um I was listening to I think I was
searching for being guilty that I'm
doing better than my parents and sisters
and stuff like that
um I hold
I think a lot of uh of guilt and and I
have you know heavy imposter syndrome
um and then I'm sure you've heard the
term like ego Maniac with an inferiority
complex so
um I'm 38 and yeah what did you survive
I got clean and sober
um when I was 26. I was a really bad
heroin addict cocaine uh I had a boy
dude alcohol yeah I was a train wreck
bro and um so
I think like I've I've it's funny I was
like thinking about this call and I'm
like you might have to do like a Trilogy
for me because there's so many layers
but of course
um there's like now I have this I've
rebuilt everything I I have a great wife
I have three little kids eight six and
three
um I've worked in the the drug and
alcohol treatment realm for a long time
and recently started my own recruiting
firmware like I staff treatment centers
all across the country
um and can we stop right there
yeah just for a second
okay
dude
you are in rare air my brother
like one percent of the one percent
yeah I I hold on hold on hold on call
them because I want to recognize that I
know so before you even ask your
question you I gotta say this you know
how
um you have that buddy from high school
and you haven't seen him in forever and
you run into them in the like a random
place and they're either
they've put on 50 pounds or they're
super shredded
yeah and the way you look at them is
like this alarm Bell like they see it
and they haven't noticed that over the
last 20 years they've kind of put on
half a pound and half a pound half a
pound and then you see somebody or they
haven't lost half a pound half a pound
half a pound
and they don't even recognize just how
incredible they are or on what kind of
slippery slope they're they're on and so
I need you to hear man
12 years up
on what I think are some of the hardest
drugs to get off of
yeah heroin because of the of the
biomechanics of it and alcohol because
it's freaking everywhere right yeah
you've done some hard hard work
yeah so hear me say man this is me and
you meeting in a grocery store and we
haven't seen you in 20 years and I just
can't get over how good you look man I'm
proud of you it's amazing
I appreciate that yeah I I need to hear
that I think it's funny like I um I'm a
big self-care seeker and so like still
do regular therapy
um you know do a lot of different
meditation stuff take courses Here There
and Everywhere
um on a big Health kick lost like 30
pounds since uh since Christmas like all
kinds of stuff but I was like talking to
my therapist
um I just did EMDR to try and like
address trauma but like all of this
circles around my fear of of money and
and losing everything and it's so black
and white uh hold on hold on I don't
think that's it
I may be wrong I may be wrong I hope not
that's what I'm calling I may be wrong
but
I'm wondering if you are doing these
things because there is a belief within
you that you will feel a certain way
when you're finally safe
yes 100 that feeling doesn't exist
that that's it because it's like I have
this feeling of like when I have this
much money it's not in the bank I'll be
okay yeah I'll tell you this when you
don't owe anybody any money
and I'll go one step further when you
have an emergency fund when you've got
money is set aside where you're your own
bank right you got six months of
expenses you get fired
there is a physiological shift that
happens inside your body it does
downshift but
that man you based on what drugs you
were into I guarantee you your childhood
was chaos wasn't it
yeah I think the interesting part
through tremendous amounts of therapy
was the chaos was almost created by me
due to boredom like my parents are still
married they have a sick marriage my dad
doesn't drink my mom I've seen maybe
drink eight glasses of wine in her whole
life
listen addiction
addiction is about relationship it's not
about substance yeah no so it's it's I
think I was always seeking like the
approval of I was the the skateboard kid
and like to you know your music guy like
the punk rock and stuff and I wasn't the
uh you know soccer playing student
council president I think that's where a
lot of it stands and I think now you
know like I'm also uh you know I found
Ramsay through you but like my emergency
fund is almost way too much I have like
well over a Year's worth of expenses
um I'm paying down the mortgage all my
kids have healthy college funds and like
I said my wife the other day like I got
to put money in Kai's college fund and
my wife's like dude she's three and like
I'm not talking like a hundred bucks I'm
talking like I need to put like five
grand in and it's so manic that it's
driving my wife nuts and I'm starting to
like feel like I don't even want to take
the kids to dinner and if you looked at
me on paper I mean liquid assets are
there the finances saving like we don't
live anywhere outside of our means but
it's like checking the bank account
you're trying to prove to your kids
that dad's all right
yeah you're trying to prove to my wife
that look look look look look look look
look look look look look at me look at
me look at me I'm doing it
yeah and they don't want that they just
want Dave man
yeah they just want Dave
yeah have you have you seen uh it kind
of Spun up and went by I was on somebody
else's shows and my friend the
minimalist show have you seen that that
conversation that I was first time I
ever talked about that publicly about my
wife which she said to me I know
oh oh my God was that when you were like
dude we got I got this other thing and
I'm going to speak another event you're
yelling in the basement and she was like
Hey we've gotta have enough yeah we've
got enough and but yo that's why I wrote
you the message on this Friday I didn't
batch the conversation I didn't have a
psychology for enough
right because I was just running and
running and running money was a source
of huge fear in my home growing up
as was
um
personal challenges I had growing up and
on top of all that uh here's the deal
man you you did heroin I made Straight
A's we both had the same trauma like my
I just they just gave me money and gave
me jobs for mine and they got on to you
for years both of us were running
yep my parents are still married too
that doesn't always matter
okay sure so the challenge here is is
not seeking a Feeling
one of the greatest gifts I've had is to
sit next to Dave and because Dave Ramsey
was a broke
crashed
East Tennessee kid from The Hills yeah
he calls him sees a self-proclaimed
hillbilly
and there's moments that he still
experiences to this day
um where he says there's times when he
gets the bill you know there's 1100
employees here a thousand employees here
for coffee just for the to for the whole
campus that was more than he he made an
entire year and he said there's still
moments when he like his breath leaves
his body because that East Tennessee kid
I have the exact same thing
the exact same thing so here's the
important thing he's taught me and I'll
pass it along to you I cannot trust my
feelings I can't I'm trying to raise
kids that will learn to trust theirs
but my feelings are entirely
untrustworthy for several reasons
and I'm fine with that
what I then have to do is kind of like
you know the basketball player Chris
Paul he's not seven feet tall so he has
to come up for Steph Curry he's he's six
two six three so he's got to learn to
shoot from really far away in in really
chaotic situations right you and I have
to figure out another way through this
thing because our bodies have been
through the ringer and our feeling
system is just going to be a lot
it's always going to be telling us
there's there's something around the
corner some around the corner somewhere
around the corner
and so that's it there's two things we
gotta do number one we have to be very
crystal clear about what finish lines
look like and we have to hold to those
ratios
what does that mean yeah I will put six
months in an emergency fund and that
will be all I will commit to that
despite how I feel
I will put this much as a percentage
into my retirement and that is it
that's it I moved the goal post on
myself all the time and I think it's
like yes because I I hit those goals and
then I'm like oh cool I made this much
last year Well if I don't make a million
this year I'm a loser I miss I'm that
and it's like that makes sense not
moving the goal posts because that's all
I ever do and by the way it's okay for
it to be both and you could have made a
million bucks last year and make 750
Grand this year and be disappointed
that's okay
yeah it's all right to feel that way
it's all right to look at your business
that went down a huge percentage right
and to look at it and go man what do we
need to look at because next year if it
goes down to 500 000 or my business my
take home has been cut in half and it's
also at the exact same time really cool
to be grateful that you're making half a
million dollars or three quarters of a
million dollars it's both and yeah right
it's both ends yeah that's that's what I
tell like my therapist like it almost I
think I also feel guilt for feeling the
anxiety because like I look at my
brother-in-law's and and my sisters and
all these people that like work very
hard and like I think you know on paper
I'm I'm relatively much more stable than
the one that they can go to and it's
like but it's not curbing the anxiety
and I think then I get like the guilt of
like you have all this like this cushion
and all these great things and your kids
go to this great school and you could
stay home and like none of that matters
none of that matters
yeah there you go the longer you're
running
the more you just drag your family it's
like it's like they're on a tube behind
a boat and the tube fell over but
they're all still hanging on and you're
just dragging them across the lake and
you're like look how fast we are and
look how big this boat is and they're
like we just want you to stop right
but listen listen here's the thing um
there's there's a part two to that story
I told about my about my wife telling me
hey we have enough yeah she was
struggling too because she grew up with
not a lot also
yeah and so when we both sat down and we
defined what enough is going to be for
the both of us
it actually included taking more
speaking gigs
but it also included me doing other
things in my off time
it also included me being very
intentional about going to see my own
counselor
very intentional about how I take care
of myself what I say no to outside of
these business opportunities
right so it's not like it all goes away
it's me and my wife get together and
co-create something and I gave you one
of them one of them is sit down with
your wife and create
the psychology of enough okay
um the second thing is
uh and here's it it's just it's just
ratios
if you're worth a hundred million
dollars right and you buy a hundred
thousand dollar car you have bought a
car that if you it means like race ratio
wise sure it's like you bought a one
thousand dollar car for somebody who
makes them like right you see I'm saying
so
lean on the ratios
give give like crazy be generous and
here's the second thing
I have to have a group of men in my life
that I Outsource a lot of these
questions to
okay
I am untrustworthy when I get fired up
to myself now I'm not gonna lie to
people at work that's not what I mean by
trustworthy I mean that I feel things
heavily
yeah this person's really pissed at me
this person's about to fire me this
person's not doesn't doesn't want me on
their team whatever
and I've got a few men in my life and
women in my life that I lean into and I
trust and say hey this just happened am
I crazy and they go yes you're being
crazy stop don't respond yep and I'll go
I have to respond because of all I'm not
gonna do it
see what I'm saying that's the hard work
and then here's the honest truth after a
decade of this my feelings are actually
becoming better signals I'm able to read
them better now but it just takes a
while
yeah
yeah you you have you've got to stop
chasing that feeling and just be
committed for a season while your body
relearns
uh I'll I'll
trying to find the right balance between
talking about some of this because I'm
not ready to talk about it all but I've
been through some pretty significant
trauma Counseling in a few maybe a month
ago I went to my counselor and I said
hey look
um
she said how are you feeling and I said
if I gave if I gave a name to it it
would be exhausted or depressed one of
those two feelings and she smiled really
big and she said your body is learning
for the first time
what normal feels like you're just gonna
have to learn what that feels like
that's cool because they're the two that
I feel so that means I'm on the right
track yeah because you've been running
forever and ever and ever and for you
not running feels like impending doom
it does it feels like somebody's gonna
call me the world's gonna fall apart I'm
gonna lose it and I did this as the EMDR
therapist and she's like you're
frustrating me because you try so hard
to understand so much that like you you
cognizantly know what's better but like
it's never going to be enough and like
you're never going to be broke in the
tent asking people like you're not gonna
be able to not provide for your kids
because you have this balance of like
really hard work but also like you're a
little bit overly neurotic with it where
like on paper you couldn't be more safe
like if you sat down with the finances
that safety is not external and you're
trying to get safe externally you can't
it's internal yeah I'll tell you this I
may have said this on the show my
counselor told me we can only you're
only going to talk
once every two or three sessions now and
here's her words you've built an
intellectual Fortress around yourself
that is very hard to penetrate and then
she said she said congratulations
and it was not in a positive way you
know what I mean it's like golf clap and
so yeah you have to practice
what does that mean sit with your kids
and play freaking Candyland until your
brain spins sideways
yeah take one of your young kids and
just go for a walk and point out every
leaf and every Acorn and if you find a
little
um I don't know a little piece of fruit
on the ground throw it at your kid and
let him throw it back at you
or if y'all go swimming do a giant
Cannonball first
go out on the boat and go really really
really slow or get some kayaks and go
even slower
you just need a couple of years of
teaching your body and I did I am
intentional a couple of years takes a
while
to teach your body
just stop running now when you get in
the business bro run
fighting claw and scratch I'm not saying
don't be ambitious and I'm not saying
when you get in the business World get
after it I'm just saying those metrics
won't heal you
what will heal you is connection
connectivity being with your family and
you just got to practice learning to sit
in that
what's uncomfortable right now but will
soon
better than any any heroin is gonna give
your body for that piece
I I can't tell you Dave how proud of you
I am so proud so proud stay on the line
here I'm going to send you a copy of my
book on your past change your future
it's my gift to you actually I'm gonna
send you two one for you and one for
your wife I want you to read it together
and I want you all to work through those
exercises together and um man it's going
to give you a road map towards building
this non-anxious life